die hauptaufgabe des österreichischen
bundesheeres ist die militärische
landesverteidigung um diese im ernstfall
gewährleisten zu können befinden sich
die soldaten im ständigen training
aber auch in friedenszeiten sorgt das
österreichische bundesheer tag für tag
dafür dass alle österreicherinnen und
österreicher in sicherheit leben können
beispielsweise durch assistenzeinsätze
an den grenzen österreichs falls
notwendig werden soldaten an den
staatsgrenzen postiert um eine illegale
einwanderung nach österreich zu
verhindern
doch nicht nur die staatsgrenzen werden
geschützt auch ausländische botschaften
und andere wichtige einrichtungen werden
vom bundesheer überwacht für den schutz
der bevölkerung sorgt auch der
entminungsdienst noch immer werden bei
grabungsarbeiten aber auch in flüssen
und seen munition und bomben die noch
aus dem zweiten weltkrieg stammen
gefunden
damit diese keinen schaden anrichten
können rücken die mitarbeiter des
entminungsdienstes mehr als 1000 mal pro
jahr aus und entschärfen die funde
doch nicht nur für gefahren im boden
sondern auch über dem boden ist das
bundesheer bestens gerüstet
die luftstreitkräfte des
österreichischen bundesheeres behalten
den luftraum rund um die uhr im auge
um gegen die virtuellen bedrohungen der
neuzeit gewappnet zu sein verfügt das
bundesheer über modernste technik und
hoch spezialisiertes personal
diese experten sorgen für den schutz von
wichtigen einrichtungen der
informationstechnologie und damit für
die sicherheit der österreicher im
internet was aber wenn ein großes
unglück geschieht wenn beispielsweise
starker dauerregen ein hochwasser
verursacht wenn lawinen oder moon
abgehen und zur gefahr werden
dann rücken die soldaten des
bundesheeres zum assistenzeinsatz aus
unterstützen die zivilen
hilfsorganisationen und sorgen so für
den schutz und die sicherheit der
österreichischen bevölkerung